[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh paulie wants to place a bet with me
all right
all pay for your dinner tonight whoo
but what do i get if i'm right
i can't i don't want to pay for your
dinner because i know how that may turn
out for me okay i won't order wine i'll
buy you a nice bottle of wine back home
okay
uh nice for me
night maybe not
a hundred dollar bottle okay then that's
good all right the bet is okay does al
michaels eat a meal
before during or before you can't do
before you're changing it it's during
the super bowl will al michaels eat
during the summer i'm fairly confident
al does eat before and after this yes
okay between some point between kickoff
and the final whistle does al eat
i'll say yes all right i'll say no al
michaels he'll be calling the super bowl
he joins us uh his 11th super bowl tying
pat sumrall for the most by a tv
play-by-play voice al will you be eating
during super bowl 56.
dan
i love my partner chris collinsworth is
like a brother
somehow someway he once said i eat a
whole meal during the game
not true
i have a few junior mints
i have some grapes i might have a
snackwell
cookie
that's it
chris is the guy who eats like a horse
before the game
sushi
pasta all of the rest okay that is fake
news okay i will not be having a meal
during the super bowl
okay uh to the judges so who won the bet
well i don't think a snack is a meal i
don't either fritzy i don't know
i'm a winner sorry paul
i like how paulie goes before during or
after the super bowl
by the way al on this date back in 2006.
you know what happened
2006. i think i left disney to go to
nbc yep
yep correct and there was a rabbit
involved in the cartoon rapid
and uh
you were uh ending a 20-year run on
monday night football now i'm just
bringing that up no reason at all that
you know maybe you're joining another
network or something on uh you know
close to this anniversary ow
uh
i have
as you well know
put all of that behind me
if you start thinking about
other things i promised myself this year
not to be distracted and i will not be
distracted until monday when i can have
a ton of distractions in my life but i
don't want anything before sunday then
i'm working like
a maniac i mean look well for your
television audience i mean i have like 9
000 pages of information ready to go for
this game the best stories
but
all of them will line up you know on the
cutting room floor as they say because
as john madden said years ago we come
armed for war we have everything
available to us
and then as john would say the game
breaks out and you do the game
but also well do you prepare for a
blowout
well i i don't think you prepare for
necessarily a blog you prepare for the
game period you hope the game is great
uh and if it's a blowout then we're
ready to go in in a different direction
it almost becomes chris and i we laughed
about it because we did have a blowout
in the
christmas weekend game between dallas
and washington and then it became almost
like talk radio you're going back and
forth fortunately for me
i've done 10 super bowls and six of them
have gone down to the to the very end
including the last four and i looked at
it this way too i don't think the nfl
has ever been hotter than it is right
now dan i mean people are just talking
about these last six games have been
fantastic and i'm just hoping that we
get the lucky seventh and it's not like
when you go to the craft table you've
got a great run going and then you throw
a seven
and the dealer says
seven out lined in new shooter we don't
need that we need we need the lucky
seven this week
how important is it for you to meet with
coaches or quarterbacks
to glean information from them
very uh and we will we're going out to
see the rams today we get the bengals
tomorrow
we know the rams very well because we
had them three times this year we've had
them several times over the past couple
of seasons uh we we know them so we'll
see you know mcveigh and we'll see
stafford and some of the other guys
today and then uh
i think chris chris knows zach taylor a
little bit because he lives in
cincinnati i've met him once
don't know burro we'll meet him tomorrow
i think it's important i think it's it's
great because you know you know enough
about them from watching them and
reading about them and then you get to
talk to them and i find you know the
really good stuff that happens is you
get
a story that hasn't been told before
going into a super bowl there's so many
stories out there millions and millions
of you know words have been written and
so much time has been spent on
television and radio talking about it
you want to find something that's a
little bit different so hopefully that's
what will happen and that's why that's
why
it's very beneficial to me with the the
principles we always talk about players
when they get to the postseason
but as a broadcaster
the amount of postseason games you call
what
changes or how does that prepare you
better for the next one you do and the
next one you do
it's you know what it's it's almost like
when you're a player dan
you know you do
what got you
there so if you go you know in a
different direction i know look i
understand the magnitude of the games
and especially the super bowl when
people say you know 100 million people
are watching you can't think about that
you want to break cleanly you want to
get off to a nice start get the game
going and very much like the players who
talk about you know the first time
there's contact a couple of plays into
the game they're playing football and
we're announcing football so you don't
want to have to think about all the
extraneous stuff once the game gets
underway
you stay within your lane i mean
chris and i have done
a couple of hundred games together and
if we try to do something different or
or uh
go outside where we normally would go
why
why do you want to do that so hopefully
the game starts we concentrate on the
game the game is close all the way and
all i root for dan is triple overtime
can't get enough of this
how where are you of i know the point
spread but prop bets
a little bit you know i
look i've been the rascal you know that
i'm the guy who's always talking about
a point spread or the over under and
i've sneaked it in through the years and
a lot of people love it uh now of course
i can come in the front door because
you've got draftkings and all these
other entities that are now involved
with with the national football league
you don't overdo it though i mean in
terms of prop bets
no i think that's that's too inside
football uh i think a few people are
involved in that i saw i looked at them
the other day i mean there are 18
million prophets so where do you go with
that i think you would be talking to a
very a very small sliver of the audience
if you went there well i didn't know if
there was a prop bet
if al michaels will say the following
yes and there he goes
[Laughter]
you know
that's interesting
i remember well years ago there was a
prop bit
and i think the first game after
deflategate and i saw it and it got a
lot of play on the internet
and i think the over under was
two or two and a half
and i said let's just get this out of
the way deflate
i went right to the oven so and there he
goes you know i can be bought dan okay
not for a hundred dollar bottle of wine
but i can't be bought okay steak dinner
add a hundred dollar bible and a hundred
dollar bond well yeah you can't have a
steak dinner without a hundred dollar
bottle
no
but um do you talk more to chris prior
to the game
or less
so you save it on the
no you know we're always we talk to each
other at least a couple of times a week
um we have our production meetings with
fred goodell and julissa cough our
producer director michelle tafoya's
working with us we've had catherine
tapper this looks like so we're all kind
of
interconnected we talk a lot to each
other so that you know we know the
stories we share stories with each other
and then we decide how we want to get
there but i mean it's going to be like a
regular game in that regard this is the
same thing we do
during the regular season as i say even
though this is the super bowl and it's a
big big big deal
we do what we do during the course of
the year
the fascination with joe burrow to be
doing this in his second year
and like
to say he's ahead of schedule is a a
grand understatement because even if
they're on schedule you wouldn't think
the bengals would be here how big a
story is that going to be on sunday
for
your broadcast
well very of course he's the quarterback
of one of the teams so obviously that
becomes a big story
right at the uh at the outset but i
think
what i sensed during the
championship game in kansas city is that
a lot of this country uh either i don't
want to say necessarily fell in love but
we're fascinated by what the bengals did
they're down 21-3 everybody's thinking
okay mahomes is going back to the super
bowl third year in a row it's kansas
city against whoever would win the ram
49er game and somehow someway i just
sensed the way they came from behind
you know for borrow nothing looks too
big for him i mean the way he stepped
out of a couple of tackles when it
looked like he was going to get sacked
running for first downs uh doing what he
did that day winning in overtime and
just uh
just his his
body language and and presence
yeah you look at a guy you think well
this guy has been in the league for 10
or 12 years but i think the country at
that point unless obviously you were
rooting for kansas city uh kind of fell
in love a little bit with the bengals
and went wow that's pretty cool so
that's the sense i get going into this
game and borough of course would be at
the forefront of all of that
you remember what you thought when the
rams left los angeles
yes i do because uh this is my hometown
and i knew that in those years of doing
monday night football and every game was
going to be a road game now i wouldn't
even get a game in anaheim um i
understood it though because the problem
in in this
city and area was that
every uh stadium was a relic and that's
why the raiders who had come down here
moved out of the coliseum uh the rose
bowl was not an nfl type of stadium a
beautiful setting but not for the nfl
anaheim stadium was really a baseball
stadium that they turned into a hybrid
football stadium
so i i understood it i was not happy
about it but like everything else these
uh moves
their their money or you know follow the
money
it's the old cliche about follow the
money and that's what the rams did st
louis gave them a great deal
a much better deal than they had in
manheim and the way they went as did the
raiders back to oakland at that same
very same point
do you think tom brady's retired
if i had to bet i would say yes i know
that there's some other
things out there after his podcast the
other day i didn't hear it i read about
it
i felt
when we did the the rams tampa game that
he that was going to be at i thought it
was like
6436
uh that he would retire he would step
away because he gave us a
an answer in terms of when i asked him
before that game about the perfect
ending he said it involves a super bowl
might not be this year and then he kind
of went back and forth a lot so
i did think he was going to step away i
wasn't surprised when he stepped away
now you've got this other thing out
there i would be i would be surprised if
he came back i'm not saying he won't and
i don't have any inside information
about this stand but um
if i you know i guess they have had to
make a bet i would say he's not coming
back
but does it work for broadcasters when
you're at the top of your game and
like you know you when how do you walk
away when do you walk away who tells you
to walk away
uh
i thought for me i mean in broadcasting
if i couldn't do
do it the way i had to do it and want to
do it and my brain
began to uh leak a little bit let's put
it that way
it would be time to walk away and i've
got some you know people who are very
very close to me who would be the first
to tell me as if i wouldn't know myself
for a player
i don't know i think it's a very hard
thing to do uh to walk away because to
recreate the buzz you get
playing in super bowls and doing what
tom did i mean he's going to have a
really good football afterlife he's very
smart he's got a lot of things going he
can do any number of things there's no
question about that and live a wonderful
life
i'm not sure you can ever recreate the
thrill the thrill that an athlete can
get when you're playing on the biggest
stage
that long i mean you can do several
things in business you can do things in
broadcasting but i'm not sure you can
you can recreate that drill and that's
why a lot of coaches sometimes will step
away go into the broadcast booth and
then go back because at the end of the
day
if you're coaching you look up at that
scoreboard at the end of the game you
know what you did did you win
did you lose in broadcasting what are
you supposed to do go on the internet
and find out that everybody loves you
forget about it
oh it's great to talk to you about and
uh as always dan as always yeah have fun
and uh your 11th super bowl that uh ties
pat sumrall for the most by tv play by
play voice and uh
michelle tafoya's last game on the
sidelines for you guys too
oh i just want to say michelle she has
been
such a great partner i've done 300
broadcasts with her
basketball we did the nba back in the 0
304 seasons
football she is the best of the best
i'll put her up against any reporter in
this country
print or electronic and you know
michelle tons of fun she keeps us
laughing we're going to miss her i'm
going to miss her terribly because i
mean she's just she's just great to be
with
thank you bud uh talk to you soon thank
you al you bet man thank you it's uh al
michaels and uh you could of course
watch the game on peacock and nbc sports
chris collinsworth and it'll be the uh
swan song for michelle tafoya who's
stepping away as the sideline reporter